i lost you
nope i'm still here i mean i lost you
i'm like okay we're good
all right guys bang
bang so before we get started
smash the like button on the video
subscribe to the channel
and we're gonna drop in the chat to go
to
jason has a new youtube channel that you
can subscribe at
um but what's up man how are you
what's going on what uh what's new
let's what are we gonna talk about today
let's uh we're gonna go for like a
hour and 15 minutes or so so what uh
what are some things that uh that you
want to cover
um well we can talk about some bitcoin
it looks like you have
um you have done a fair amount of work
on
is bitcoin good money is ethereum good
money
probably like to talk about that a
little bit i'd love to get your
opinion on defy because again
it seems like you've been doing some
work there maybe we can unpack why
people think that you're a bitcoin
maximalist
i i think that's uh that's interesting
uh although you don't own any eth
which we we should also talk about
because i
i find that to be nearly impossible
but um we'll see we'll see um i don't
know man uh north carolina we've had uh
hurricane
tornado and an earthquake in one week
which i think is seems
calm seems calm 2020.
all right so let's let's start with
bitcoin and
ether as money um
they're both money in the sense that
money is just a belief system so if two
people
or organizations are willing to transact
them uh
then they are quote unquote uh a
currency right
we'll put it as a currency the problem
is
which one is good and which one is bad
and i don't mean that in the sense that
i come at it from one has to be good and
one has to be bad
but i do believe that there's a big
divergence
in um the framework of
bitcoin versus the framework of ether do
you mind if while we talk i kind of jump
in and interrupt you a little bit
because i think
there are words that we use that are
really important
and when i say good money like i want to
understand what your
your feelings are or definition of
good money is because i find money
right but take take it a little deeper
than that like what what should
money do that makes it good
it should protect your wealth right
and how does it protect your wealth like
what how how does that happen
so think think a little bit deeper or
talk to me a little bit more about
why why should good money protect your
wealth
well it all goes back to um what are you
optimizing for
right and i think that uh in a world
where a currency is
uh devalued over time um or it has
unlimited supply uh regardless of how
that is
uh created what you end up getting is
you get a
very non-equitable world and what i mean
by that is
those who hold the currency end up
losing value over time
and those who get out of the currency
and get into
investment assets end up uh making money
or getting wealthier so the rich get
richer poor get poorer
if you take a that to kind of bitcoin
versus ether
bitcoin is a perfect example of uh the
soundest money right and what i mean by
that is uh
one it has a artificially capped supply
so let's compare
what is another popular sound money to
gold so nobody knows what
gold's total available supply is right
we love that peter
peter schiff admitted to that during
your debate which i thought was a really
interesting moment and i don't know if
he really thought about it
because people do try to define you know
stock to flow of gold or how much gold
is really here like i think he could
have answered it better but
he said it's infinite yeah well it's
so there's our there's the really really
outlandish like ridiculous position
which is to say something like
uh there's gold on asteroids and we're
gonna mine those in 30 years and
therefore
like it you know gold has an infinite
supply but i i would i wouldn't even go
to mining in space but
just trying to contemplate how much
gold's in the ocean yeah
so that's too hard too gold in the ocean
right
gold under the ground could you uh
actually create
gold right if you remember
gold so one of the one of the jokes and
before people freak out right i'm half
joking when i say this
it is widely accepted in the gold
community that gold is created from
stars
right sure and so there's an argument to
say
it's just alien rocks right like it's
created
from stars and ends up here on earth
and so you can create gold
if you have all of the right inputs and
and process and all that
now that is that is directionally and
something i
yeah that makes a lot of sense to me
right if you have the right chemistry
and right circumstances you can create
gold
now with that said gold is quote unquote
scarce in the sense of it's hard to
dig up out of the ground so it cost
money right there's a difficult process
there is not gold laying all over the
floor
right so it's not abundant in the sense
of everyone has gold in their pockets
and you know
hanging around and it's falling off
trees and all that kind of stuff
so in a analog world
where the story of an asset was more
important than the actual
provability of the asset but the story
of the asset
for thousands of years gold took on this
narrative of
it was scarce and scarce is relative
right so if it's harder to find than
other
assets of course yeah it's quote unquote
scarce but it you can't
prove the scarcity and what i mean by
that is we have no clue
if somebody tomorrow hits a gold deposit
and floods the market now again i'm not
claiming that that is likely
or probable but i'm just saying that the
possibility creates a situation
that we'll get to in a second uh is no
longer necessary
the second thing is we don't know how
much gold
actually has been discovered so we don't
know the total addressable supply
and we also don't know the circulating
supply now
not a huge issue in the sense of uh
you can still buy gold create jewelry
you can still buy gold and hold it do
all these different things there's a
market so there's buyer and sellers like
all of that is true
but what i'm specifically getting at is
there is
no provable scarcity the scarcity is
a story and there are data points that
you can use and kind of intertwine in
that story to
to tell the story but you cannot say
what is the total adjustable market uh
the total adjustable gold available
uh with any level of accuracy and proof
ability and you also can't do that for
circulating supply
now it still is considered sound money
right it's served to sound money for a
long time because of
that story and that scarcity when you
look at bitcoin
bitcoin solves that problem in a
very unique important way which is
bitcoin
you can prove the total um
available bitcoin in terms of the total
supply
and you can also prove the current
circulating supply and so now what ends
up happening is you move from a
scarcity asset based on a story
and a common belief to in a digital
world
you move to something that can be proven
so they're both
sound money one is provable the other
isn't and i think
that while it seems like a very small
nuanced detail
is incredibly valuable as we look at
over the next 50 plus years
yep that's probably right it seems that
scarcity
is bubbling up as a hot topic right now
specifically in kind of the bitcoin
maximalist world
that have turned their focus to eth um
and the question of eth being money and
eth even being able to prove
how many eth there are look it
i've wrote uh i forget exactly when i
wrote it but i wrote a while ago
eth is not good money right and what i
meant by this
is there is a meme uh that goes around
and be actually before you even get to
the meme
there's two parts to the ethereum
ecosystem one is ethereum the network
and the other is ether the digital asset
i'm a huge fan right i wrote this
morning about i'm a huge fan of the
ethereum network right we've invested in
companies that are building on top of it
we're invested in in businesses that
literally are hiring ethereum developers
all that kind of stuff and i believe
that the ethereum network
is going to empower an incredible amount
of innovation
over the coming years right it is going
to be one of the core pieces of
infrastructure to build a decentralized
world but with that said
the ethereum narrative has started to
shift
and now you've got a bunch of people
running around because they see
decentralized finance as something that
can be built
with ethereum and now they start yelling
and screaming ethan's money
no it's not right eth is being used as a
tradable asset
but when you look at the actual
structure
it is identical to a fiat currency and
what i mean by that
is one there is no total supply there's
no set supply so it's an unlimited
supply as of today that could change but
as of today it's an unlimited supply
two all of the inflationary or
deflationary decisions
are made non-programmatically
meaning that there is votes and it is a
response
to the current environment as we have
seen humans are
horrible at this they overreact in times
of fear right and they
they under react in times in the good
times and so this is true in the fiat
world this is going to be true in in the
ether world
now to the ethereum community's credit
right and i try to be kind of think of
both sides the positive and negatives
to their credit every time that they've
had to make this
uh monetary supply decision they have
decreased the supply
so they've done the right thing so far
in terms of decreasing the supply
but the possibility exists where they
could
increase the supply schedule and so that
is very similar right the the u.s
federal reserve can decrease or increase
the monetary supply right same thing
with with the ether well
and then when you kind of get outside of
that the key piece that came up this
weekend
was the provability now it got
solved right but the thing that caught
my attention was not
that specific issue right okay great and
and by the way it's
comical that pure roshard who is a
bitcoin proponent
paid for yeah put put a bounty out to
pay for to get the script written by the
way
it's solved right so there's now a open
source script that's available
i'm not worried about the one specific
issue
what i was shocked by was the
cavalierness and the nonchalantness of
the ethereum community
to what is a pretty simple question how
many ether exist
and to hear people say it doesn't matter
or
we're close enough but yet be off by 343
000 ether which is 130 plus million
dollars
it's like wait a second what else is not
that important or you're close enough to
right and so again it comes back to this
thing and
actually ethereum has the same exact
thing
that bitcoin cash has right so i'm gonna
make two connections here that i think
will will kind of
uh start to tie a lot of these assets
together and why the bitcoin community
has such a staunch belief in something
there is no difference between bitcoin
cash
and ethereum both saying it's not
important
for individuals to run full notes or
have the ability to run full nodes
right they both make that claim and so
today
or this past weekend what we saw was if
you had an ethereum node and i had one
and we both queried the same blockchain
at the same time
we could potentially get two different
answers that's not good
right that's been fixed right so it's no
longer an
issue at the moment but it is
very enlightening when people are saying
things like it's close enough or they're
taking pictures of
third-party data providers and saying
like oh here's the supply
like this whole idea of don't trust
verify right
that is what is enabled by this new
digital
world where you can prove you can verify
things and as a fan of ethereum the
network
i was shocked to see that reaction and i
get it some of it's the tribalism
right they see bitcoin you know uh folks
saying things so immediately your
reaction is to fight back
so so kind of ignore all that but it
just goes back to
why is this stuff important it's all
about the provability
not so much just the oh trust me because
that looks very similar to a fiat
currency
yep agree or disagree no no i i agree
with
um i agree with your point i think
there's um a lot that we should discuss
around inflation and deflation because i
i've been
always um it's it's a it's a complicated
uh it's a complicated discussion but
it's something that
even recently i've just i've been
overwhelmed with
the deflationary aspects of bitcoin and
how important they
are uh and i wanted to add one data
point it looks like
uh peter mccormick has gotten
vitalik buterin to agree to
a just discussion with samson mao
um which will be interesting you know i
hope that peter is able to
to be impartial and really sit between
that
and allow for a good discussion i'm not
interested in
you know people trying to measure their
dicks
in in a fight but i i'd like to have an
intelligent
kind of discussion and an exploration of
these topics with
you know people who know a lot about it
yeah well here's one other thing that
i'm going to say
which uh if you are watching this right
now
you're going to have to have an open
mind to hear this uh this mental pretzel
which is i actually believe
the price of ether is going to increase
significantly in this next bull market
and it is likely it may outperform
bitcoin
i actually think it's likely that on a
on a pure us dollar value
the price of ether is likely to go up
more than the price of bitcoin now
people will say well what do you mean so
two factors into that first of all
is whenever you see a market where there
are large cap assets and small cap
assets today bitcoin's market caps about
5x out of ethereum
when you get into a bull market and all
assets rise the smaller cap
assets will almost always appreciate
more than the large cap assets
right so that's kind of the first thing
that's going in ether's favor
uh if you're looking at it from a pure
financial return perspective
the second thing is look at
the drawdown from the current all-time
high bitcoin's down about
40 give or take ethereum's down 70
from its all-time high so if they just
go back to their all-time highs you get
about a 60
increase on the bitcoin side you get a
400 increase on the
ether side now if you simply want to be
a trader
and look for financial return knock
yourself out use that data however you
want right not financial advice but like
use that however you want i personally
believe though
that there is a big difference or a
divergence between
ethereum and ether and it goes back to
where else have we seen this
there's actually another cryptocurrency
or a crypto asset
where we see this exact divergence which
is ripple and xrp
so my argument for xrp and ripple has
always been the ripple
software company the actual private
entity that is the software company
that's selling software to banks
i wish i was an investor in ripple the
software company
right i would have loved to be a seated
investor because the company's worth
billions of dollars
and it's a pure sas based company right
they sell software to banks awesome
when retail investors go and buy xrp
because they believe that oh if the
banks adopt ripple then xrp's value will
increase
you lose me so the the investment thesis
breaks down for the liquid digital asset
same with ethereum beneath which is
even though ethereum is going to be this
core piece of infrastructure
that does not necessarily mean that the
fat
protocol thesis is true and the price of
eath has to go up
right actually i think many people have
proven that the fat protocol thesis is
not
correct and so what you end up getting
is the the price appreciation of ease
is driven by something else it's not
driven by the adoption of
ethereum the network used as
infrastructure to help people build
applications
it's built by this it's uh driven by the
speculation
that is happening in those applications
so look at the current use cases for
uh eth coins cdps
defy right i seos all those kind of
stuff nfts
nft all of that right now again
you can separate it and it takes a very
open mind to do this and people will
freak out but it will take a very open
mind to understand
that aetherium and eth are two different
things in terms of one could be
successful without the other and by the
way the
the opposite is true too eath could
explode in price
and ethereum could not be adopted at all
it would just be pure speculation
right so these two things are not
interchangeable i think that the key
difference is um if you look at the
bitcoin network versus the ethereum
network
more people believe in the long-term
value of bitcoin
than they do in ether and people say
well how do you know that well i'm using
one specific data point
you can choose to agree or disagree with
it the data point is
over i think it's 62 or 63 percent
of people have not sold or moved
their bitcoin in the last 12 months
it's like 56 or 57 percent for
ethereum so you're telling me an asset
that is
a 5x larger market cap more people hold
the asset for longer periods of time
than the smaller cap asset you start to
say wait a second
now again that doesn't mean you should
go change your entire investment thesis
it's all about what you're optimizing
for whatever
but that's just the data points that
people have to start looking at and so i
always go back and say look i'm not
doing this just to get rich if that was
the case
i would just lever up on the latest [ __ ]
coin that somebody's pumping it goes up
500 percent you know you're 20x levered
and you make a killing
that's what it's about it's just these
ecosystems have two different
things one's inflationary one's
deflationary and
they're trying to solve different
problems and they should both double
down on what they're good at
yeah but i mean i i want to make it
clear though you're not
just in it for the tech because i i that
that's
that's not true i mean you you have
decided
to put a fair amount of your net worth
in this
investment or in this space both
to protect it from all the things that
we're talking about
but also to benefit from all the things
that we believe
bitcoin offers you oh yeah look look my
belief is that the us dollar is going to
fail at some point in my lifetime
and bitcoin will be the global reserve
currency and maybe i'm off in terms of
does it happen
you know i probably got 50 you know if
i'm lucky 60 years left
and so can it coexist it doesn't have to
fail but they could co-exist
they could absolutely coexist but so far
the us dollar and the bolivia are
co-exist too but like the bolivia failed
so you could fail and it not
disappear right but but in the sense of
the global reserve currency i believe
will ultimately be bitcoin it goes back
to
in the digital world if you can prove
things versus trust people and
organizations
i believe that the superior model is to
prove things and
look that there's people who i think
are in positions of power whether that
is world leaders
uh congressmen in the united states etc
who are starting to wake up to this idea
and it's unpopular today i think it
eventually will become
more or less taboo right and then
eventually
just become the popular idea and the
beauty is
nobody has to crown something one way or
the other
it's just people as they trade decide to
use something else and so i think that's
where we're headed
um and so the belief isn't like hey i i
think there's a lot of people in crypto
who say
i'm gonna invest in something i'm gonna
wait for it to go up i'm gonna sell it
back into dollars and then i'm gonna
like
go buy a house or buy a jet or or do
whatever
right that's not my belief my belief is
that
the bitcoin that we are buying today
will ultimately be something that you
like literally passed down to your kids
kids
right because it's going to be like
those families
you know 100 plus years ago 200 years
ago 500 years ago who are like hey
here's all the gold
yeah i was just gonna say you you sound
like every time the stock market runs
and then you start to hear the gold
commercials on the financial networks
it's like
it's like an old man or an old lady
saying you know
uh the stock market's got me a little
worried and uh
i find comfort and i can sleep at night
because i own gold
and then they go into this big gold
mantra
and it's funny to hear those commercials
right now pomp
and then the next commercial is like
grayskill bitcoin trust or grayscale
trust you know it's like the history of
money and
and i mean that's really playing out
right now so
you know and one other data point i
wanted to to lift up because i take a
lot
a lot of heat i don't know if i may take
more heat than you do on this topic
because
i tend to look at bitcoin ethereum
altcoins and [ __ ] coins and i talk
openly about them i i find you don't
you don't talk about roon very often so
yeah right
so that that's more of my kind of world
but
you know andreas antonopoulos feels
pretty much as you and i do like he
takes a tremendous amount of heat
for exploring the intellectual
kind of being intellectually curious and
thinking about ethereum and just as
you've described i think
he would uh be directly in favor of the
things you've discussed today
yeah and look what i think is probably
the most misunderstood
thing about the bitcoin community is if
you hear what i just said right
a world where i said i believe that uh
it is likely
eth will appreciate more than bitcoin in
the next bull market
yet i hold none what you start to
realize is
there's a a divergence i think in terms
of
the bitcoin community doesn't re they're
the hardcore
kind of the people that uh folks would
say like oh that's a bitcoin maximalist
what i think actually is ends up i mean
those guys are starting to like fight
about big block and small block size i
mean
it gets it gets heated internally and
not yeah anyway
the way that i think about it is uh
the most important thing that the human
race is working on
right now the most important thing hands
down bar none
is if we can figure out how to
successfully
move back to sound money it will have
lasting ramifications across every facet
of society
right and i'm talking about very
material and so if you go back
and you look at everything that has been
created
coming out of the sound money right and
coming off of the gold standard and all
this kind of stuff
what you realize is it has made
the world incredibly unfair
and what i mean by that is you have a
system that is built
that 50 plus percent of people they
can't get ahead
they will not be able to get ahead
because ultimately the system that
they're in
wait a minute would you say that coming
off of the gold standard
created the system of rehypothecation
it's not even that like like that's such
like a minute detail in terms of the big
picture and the big picture is
right now in the united states 45 of
americans
own no investable assets right and by
the way i don't mean to interrupt you
if you get into kind of um different
demographics of people
um it's shocking the amount of debt and
the lack of assets
and and it's it's it's scary actually
yeah and and when you understand like
that is the average
american right i'll speak specifically
to americans that's the the country
obviously or the economy that i'm most
familiar with
but so 45 they don't own any investable
assets 50
can't come up with 400 bucks for an
emergency payment so that means that
they live paycheck to paycheck
all of their wealth is sitting in cash
and they don't have a lot right
and now what you get is you get an
inflationary system which the argument
says
oh we have to do this to spur economic
activity
right that is the argument behind this
inflation but
what they don't tell you is that the
arbitrary
nature of that inflationary system
and the ability to print unlimited
amount of money
ends up actually being the greatest
cause of wealth inequality in the world
and so what people end up having to make
a decision of is
it's not like gold which is sound money
was not inflationary previously
there was still some gold added to the
circulating supply it was just really
hard to produce right to get it
and so what you get is it was a very
very low inflation percentage and also
there was nobody who could just wake up
one day and say
i think i'm just going to create more
right and so i think
that's where you ultimately get the rich
get richer the poor get poorer and we've
seen that the data is indisputable that
the rich have gotten richer and the poor
have gotten poorer
and there are also the anecdotal pieces
of evidence my favorite stat right now
the billionaires in the united states in
the last five months have made over
half a trillion dollars while there are
50 plus million americans who lost their
job
think about that for a second and what
we saw was we saw the federal reserve
step in they printed
trillions of dollars they pumped
liquidity into the market
asset prices exploded yeah
right so you just get in this world of
like what's the number one thing we
could do
if bitcoin becomes the global reserve
currency i believe it will have a more
positive impact on the world than all
philanthropy combined
because what you'll do is you'll
literally rebuild the structure
to have a more equitable world now that
is a
big big task right and there's a lot of
things that can go wrong
there's a lot of obstacles that is not
going to be easy and it's not going to
be
tomorrow that is a multi-decade type
thing
but if it happens the impact would be
bigger than anything else that anyone's
working on
interesting you know i i forget who
tweeted this i think it was pure richard
he said that bitcoin will solve wars we
uh we we actually had a counter thesis
to that that i've explored with bitcoin
tina in the past
uh we actually both believe bitcoin will
cause wars uh imagine if the things that
you're saying
happen and bitcoin becomes
a global reserve currency it totally
consumes the market cap
of gold it starts to consume the market
cap of
of of different commodities real estate
all the fiat in the world and it's
moderately centralized
where banks didn't get a chance to front
run it and individuals own
large amounts of bitcoin that could be
worth some number that
um
okay you there yeah i'm here all right i
don't know uh last i heard was
um uh the individuals have a large
amount of bitcoin
right i was saying that imagine if
bitcoin starts to consume the mark
market cap of of stocks bonds currencies
commodities it starts to take out gold
it takes out real estate takes out
all of global money supply i'm just i'm
just riffing here but
imagine bitcoin is five million dollars
of bitcoin and it's sort of centralized
you've got a bunch of individuals that
own a lot of bitcoin
banks didn't get a chance to front run
it how does that not cause
like wars well the us dollar
the us dollar is definitely more
centralized than bitcoin
right so if you look in the united
states there's literally
you know it was a two percent of people
uh or
or i think it's the top one percent owns
99 of the assets
right so when you look at it from that
standpoint the us dollars
is definitely much more centralized uh
in terms of ownership
but but the second piece of it is uh
war doesn't solve that problem
in what way if i have bitcoin and you
kill me
you don't get the bitcoin well um
there's always a negotiation before
and after war pump so that war is just
a potential unnecessary step but it
happens on occasion so
yeah when you have war then you have
some type of a an agreement coming out
of the war and that agreement could be
give me all your bitcoin or war
continues
but but i think that that's what people
don't realize that's really how war
works
so is but that doesn't change
anything to do with bitcoin
right because ultimately what ended what
ends up happening is
in today's world the reason why you
don't see
war in terms of i'm coming to steal
your physical assets right the last two
times we've seen that
have really been over oil right as a
commodity
but you can't take the oil with you back
to your country
it's in the ground and so you can occupy
right or you can have some sort of as
you're talking about
arrangement where basically like we get
a cut
and that's what happens now the
difference here
is um when you look at
bitcoin every time that there's ever
been global conflict those global
conflicts
uh end up somebody takes out the
superpower and then they install their
currency as the global reserve currency
the difference this time is that was
almost i think that's what happened with
the british pound yeah it was world war
ii right it but but here's what you have
to remember is
that's in an analog world right is where
violent conflict
you have to first take out the person
that
has the global reserve currency in order
to implement your own
and the way you do that is you show
superior military might
in a digital world it's the exact
opposite
you have to have the greatest defense to
have the superior
might right it's not military might but
it's the superior power
is whoever has the greatest defense and
so we can go and hack
china all we want or china can hack us
but if we just kick you out
then it doesn't really matter right it's
whoever has the greatest defense
and so what i think is going to happen
is bitcoin
will ascend to the global reserve
currency status
and never fire a single bomb bullet or
any sort of violence and the reason is
because it doesn't have to take out the
current global reserve currency
because if you go to attack bitcoin
there's nobody to attack
you can't shut down the network and
there's nobody to fight back against
but there is a war and many many smart
people
have contemplated the war that china
would bring against the united states
would never fire a bullet pump but it
would be an economic war
and and that's sort of what we're
dealing with now in
in my opinion that we're in an economic
war
and there's another participant and
that's bitcoin
but the thing is that you can't have an
economic war with bitcoin
every every every single attack that you
have
has no effect on bitcoin so the the old
model
of we're gonna go to war with something
they've always fought something that's
centralized
so you could do it economically you can
do it through society you can do it
through military might you can do all
this stuff
none of that impacts bitcoin and that's
the beauty of decentralization
so the economic war you can't have an
economic war with
uh a decentralized currency that
is fully distributed fully decentralized
and has no other
gdp has no other output right you know i
i find it really funny
because i do watch peripheral projects
and i think it's adam back they launched
that
satellite and they transmitted some
bitcoin over satellite
and i always think like why would you go
through all that pain to do that
and it really probably comes uh
as a result of them contemplating attack
vectors
like if i if i wanted to shut off the
internet
you could shut off bitcoin but then
why can't you because you're not going
to be able to get global coordination to
shut down the internet on a global basis
um but you can shut it off in a country
of course but but i can still but you
don't take my bitcoin when you do that
no that that's right but you stop
potentially my ability to
to send or trans you affect some of its
portability
absolutely there would be an impact
right it would be crazy to say that it's
not
but it goes back to this idea of um
you still have the core piece which is
the sovereignty of the asset allows you
to
protect your wealth and so that it's
such a
different thing and such a divergence
from the way that we've thought about
currencies and money and and war and all
this kind of crazy stuff
that myself other people everyone is
still thinking through this stuff
right and we're gonna see how it plays
out right but i do
think that um if we are incorrect about
bitcoin
it is likely that we are underestimating
how important and impactful it will be
rather than overestimating it right and
it's because it's a market expanding
technology right it's when you have a
digital world
and you take a analog business right i
always say
what analog business do you know that
went on the internet and is smaller than
it was when it was analog
none right same thing here is
by digitizing this stuff it's only going
to get bigger
not smaller and so when it gets bigger
store a value asset like gold bitcoin
will be bigger at some point i have no
clue when
right i don't know if that's a again 10
years 50 years could be 300 years
but at some point all of the the
structure
and the system and the mechanism and the
provability all of these things
are superior right the portability the
divisibility the the digital nature like
it's all
superior and so what ends up happening
is
you just need time to occur and
ultimately
people will gravitate towards that value
the big question is just how long does
that take and how quick does it happen
right i don't know one of the things
that you know i found
probably recently i hate to admit that
is i kept
even half a decade ago questioning the
use cases of bitcoin
but the things we're discussing right
now are the use case it seems like it
always was the use case
that this is sound money
i mean i i don't even think that it's
debatable at this point
whether bitcoin is the most sound money
in the world or not
there's not a single you know look
here's the crazy part
your city proves scarcity gold
u.s dollars and ethereum all have
unlimited supply as they are designed
today
yep right because there's no cap and now
some people look at that as a negative
but when you start to understand and
unpack
the value of provable scarcity provable
cap to an asset it ends up being pretty
compelling
then i also add and i i don't know if
you've used this term before
i listen to you speak a lot and we do a
lot of pitches together
but i i think bitcoin is infinitely
divisible
i mean essentially yes right there's
people who will debate the uh the finer
points of mathematics but yes
essentially
so you have 21 million bitcoin and it
it's infinitely divisible so as the
price goes up
and if you if you chose to transact with
it
you can there is actually enough yeah
and i think that people
forget you transact today with
digital goods or digital assets right
so when i go online and i
buy something on amazon right or i or i
uh
transact with you i send you information
or value right
it's just that the the difference here
is
the monetary policy and then the
provability of that monetary policy
and so every currency in the world in my
opinion is going to be
digital every single one us dollar will
be digital all of these right and
digital being
you know some sort of either blockchain
based or
a variation of a blockchain where it's
not the electronic money when i use the
terminology
hey pomp i actually think it's going to
happen
uh before the nations
digitize their currency banks
will have a digital asset that
represents
their saw their currency and that's how
it'll be digitized
they'll first say that it's a stable
token backed one-to-one
by their said currency and then
they'll dump that and become central
banks themselves
yeah it's the corporate central bank
thesis like
every single one of them is going to try
to do this and i actually believe
right and wrote about the fact i think
that politicians should
immediately implement a rule that says
if you are a bank a private corporation
whatever
you cannot create a digital currency
tied to a currency or a commodity backed
one to one
and then in the future unpeg it so
if you want to create a different one
later on peg to something else you're
not pegged anything knock yourself out
but you can't drive adoption under one
promise or thesis
and then later change it by completely
removing
the peg it's happening like i absolutely
think that will happen
and and i hope that politicians or the
treasury or the fed
uh is thinking this way of course i mean
i can't i that has to be the motivation
of jp morgan
and uh and the like making stable tokens
of course before i forget if you're
watching this right now
couple of housekeeping things one smash
the like button on this so more people
on youtube can see the content
two make sure you're subscribed to the
channel three
go to jason's youtube channel which is
called going
parabolic p-a-r-a-b-o-l-i-c
higher make sure that you're subscribed
to going parabolic he goes live every
single morning
no brainer and then also go sign up at
pompletter.com and you can get the email
i write every day so
like this video subscribe to this
channel go subscribe to jason's channel
going parabolic
and then sign up for pompletter.com
all right i got questions for you
let's uh put bitcoin to the side for a
second what do you think is happening in
the macro economy and what would you do
as an investor what are you doing
um you know i was listening to ralph
paul uh recently
and he you know i love when people
that i respect confirm a strategy i've
deployed
so you know i have a pretty large
position about 12 percent of my net
worth in bitcoin
um and i think that's really really
important
and i'm probably moving that to 15
i own gold i own silver i don't have
cash i typically was someone who had a
large portion about 20
let's say 10 to 20
of my net worth was in cash uh just to
be opportunistic
that money has been moved to digital
assets
uh specifically stable tokens so i'm i'm
enjoying
um that stranded
asset that was being subjected to
inflation
and kind of being stolen from me uh it's
working now
and um i like that i love real estate
so i'm making a lot of moves in
residential real estate that i
understand
i'm kind of waiting for a commercial
real estate collapse
which i think will happen um
it seems to be playing out and i'd like
to try to pick up some
some high quality commercial real estate
um
and uh i don't have any real exposure to
the stock market
i missed that whole upside but you know
i've done
i've done just fine sitting on the
sidelines there
um i think there's a lot of inflation
that's been hidden there
i think that ppp and the fed have
propped up a lot of companies that
probably should have went out
um out of business what happens with
that
like i agree with you that they
basically are just saving dying
businesses
and just prolonging the inevitable how
do you think that plays out well i think
it flies in the face
of free market capitalism and kind of
what should happen like let me use this
example which i spoke about this morning
on going parabolic
you saw jcpenney and sears file chapter
11.
they went bankrupt and they exist as
anchor tenants in a lot of u.s malls
so it obviously hurts the real estate
market hurts retail
uh and it eventually could hurt banks
who are holding the paper on these
mortgages
but when you let the free market work
itself out
you get this to happen
amazon walks in and says you know what
rather than me building a million square
foot
distribution center let me go into the
mall
and put my distribution center there and
when you think about
that because i've used that thesis over
two decades pomp
i put fast meds into blockbusters and
fast methods into cookouts and fast meds
into
you know mattress firms and i repurposed
real estate
and i guarantee you it will it will be
worth its weight in gold this thesis
that someone at amazon came up with
because they're going to be able to
rapidly expand
into these big spaces with big parking
lots
and cheap power and revitalize
malls and bring jobs to to people
and i think that's that's something i
support so that that
that's my financial conservatism that's
me supporting free market capitalism
and that's an example of what can happen
if you let these companies go out of
business
but when you prop them up like we have
you kind of don't allow for the good
things to happen the things that have
made america great
you know like even this kodak thing it
just
perverts things like you have a 765
million dollar
loan to kodak from the fed
to turn it into a pharmaceutical company
they may have expertise in chemicals but
this is a pivot that
if it was really something that should
happen pomp
the kodak investors the people who love
kodak who own the stock
and the leadership should have went to
the market with it and let the people
invest in it but then you get this
perverted stock option thing and
and now the sec has put the brakes on
the loan and
um i i i've kind of rambled about
but that that's how i feel so
macroeconomically that's how i'm playing
the game
um from a free market capitalist
perspective
i wish they'd let let the chips fall
like let it happen like i i felt
instinctively like
when the fed and the government shut
down small businesses
and knocked out you know 70 years
100 years of jobs that were created
they should have done something but i
think we're
in qe forever now like i really do i
i don't i don't see how how we get
unemployment back into single digits
i don't think that they can stop i mean
we pretty much already knew they
couldn't stop printing right when they
tried that or quantitative tightening uh
you know laughable in terms of just the
gyrations of the market it's very
difficult obviously
and pom this may be mmt without anyone
saying it
yeah well it's um i think it's uh travis
klinge was the first person that i heard
say this i don't know if
other people have said it before him but
he was the first that i heard say
quantitative easing is just
ubi for rich people right basically
every time they do quantitative easing
they're just bailing out the rich people
and if you look
we saw it perfectly over the last five
months which is the rich got richer the
poor got poorer
and that's because the government
decided to
do that and by the way that even
happened while they were sending 1200
checks directly to people like all this
you know nonsense about oh we're bailing
out the people
right no it's not about bailing out the
people but you know i said right as soon
as i heard that twelve hundred dollars
that is a payment to not have social
unrest
that's right we gave you 1200 bucks we
gave you 1200 bucks right
but we just gave jeff bezos 40 billion
dollars
that's right net worth do you do you
believe
that inflationary environments make the
rich richer
and the poor poorer of course you know
i've had some people
um try to to to say that's flawed logic
but i just
i it seems very simple to me
don't hold cash they have hard assets
and those hard assets
benefit in inflationary environments
what's their argument
against that oh you know i probably
can't even articulate it
very well because it was just illogical
to me i just wondered if you
if you had a a counter thought to that
i think that there's a lot of people who
uh
are in the bitcoin and crypto world
who are talking about economics
and other things and they don't have a
good grasp of
many of the basics let alone the
intricacies
uh i by no means i'm claiming that i'm
some expert either
but i do believe that um we don't do a
good job of educating people on this
stuff uh
and there's a lot of people that are
basically preying on
the lack of education and politicians
are the worst offenders
right that this idea of uh hey i'm just
gonna give you money i'm gonna give you
money
um you know one of my favorite things
and and uh peter schiff
is probably the guy who's nailed this
the best um and i've heard him say it
multiple times
and he and he couldn't be more accurate
is um
we live in a world where he really
focuses on uh this whole idea
of they're stealing your wealth right
through the inflation and then also what
they'll do is they'll say things like
we're giving you tax cuts and when you
really kind of unpack it
they're not giving you a tax cut right
they're finding other ways to actually
take more money from you and so i went
and i started like really digging into
um the u.s federal budget and all this
kind of stuff and so
the data and i might be off a little bit
if i don't remember the numbers exactly
correct but in the last
six fiscal years each year we have set a
new record
in terms of federal income tax revenue
so we've taken
more every year for six consecutive
fiscal years
from the citizens so kind of raised
taxes on an
aggregate level in the united states and
got more income from that
yet each year the
annual deficit continues to increase
so not just the total deficit but
each year the gap between income and
expenses
was getting wider and wider and wider
this year
we may have a multi-trillion dollar
deficit
in the united states and you start to
think about that you say wait a second
this isn't it's not a revenue problem
it's an expense problem right and when
you start to under
i don't mean to interrupt you but how
about this um
it doesn't matter and the government's
contemplating just
getting ditching taxes right so they're
not even concerned
about the the revenue spend gap
well why do they need to collect federal
taxes if they can just create money
that's right right now again i actually
believe
if we had the right financial system
taxes all this stuff would make sense in
terms of
okay that's where you get your revenue
from you use those revenues you have
expenses you
actually uh settle your books you've got
a little bit of profit you can use that
to pay
into things like social security all
this kind of stuff right
yesterday people freaking out or two
days ago whenever i tweeted it about
social security system
it's a ponzi scheme right now they can
say that it's pay as you go right
this is like the classic government
thing oh it's a pay as you go
what that means is jason you're going to
pay into the social security system
and we're going to immediately take your
money and we're going to pay it out to
another
uh person who invested that's how
they're going to get their returns we're
going to use your money to pay
them back for their investment that is
that is the definition of a ponzi scheme
hopefully you're not the last person
holding the bag now
so that's definitely one thing but now
if you go back to how it was designed
the idea was jason would contribute
money
into the system that system would then
take the money
it would earn interest and it would use
the interest payment or the interest
payments from jason's deposits
to go ahead and pay out
people but the problem is that
we no longer can use the interest
payments from jason's deposits or or
payments into the system
to pay the obligations and so we had to
start doing was dipping into the actual
deposits
to now we're in a system where we can
only keep the system afloat
if we continue to use the deposits into
the system to pay out
and so it wasn't intended to be a ponzi
scheme but it evolved into that
interest rates came down there was a
much longer life expectancy than
originally calculated demographics
changed
all these moving parts the highly
complex problem there's a belief in the
united states
from everyone from studies have been
done at wharton school of business
all the way to um you know nonprofits
and
all these groups that this social
security system could be insolvent
in the next 15 to 20 years and it's like
little things like that
right where we say why is that how is
that
and it all goes back to the the monetary
structure that we have
is an incentive for things to go wrong
and when things are incentivized to go
wrong they usually do
so we're seeing it over and over and
over again and i love the system that uh
morty bent says
or the phrase that he uses he says uh if
you want to fix the world fix the money
and i think that's a perfect way to
think about this is if you want to fix
the world
fix the money
oh did i lose him
let's see here i think i might have lost
jason
or maybe jason lost me
let's see
jason are you still there
maybe maybe not
all right guys i think i might just be
here by myself at the moment hopefully
we'll get uh we'll get jason back here
in a minute uh while we're waiting for
him to come back couple of things
make sure that uh like the video smash
that like button that thumbs up
make sure that more people will see this
on youtube we need to get the word out
about this important information so hit
the like button
and then go to pompletter.com
again pompletter.com and you can go
ahead and subscribe to the daily email
that i sent
uh or that i send every single morning
to over 50 000 investors
so i will drop the link right now in
the chat but make sure you go to
pompletter.com and subscribe
uh make sure you smash the like button
on the video
and subscribe to the channel i'll start
taking some questions we're waiting for
jason to come back
make sure that uh let's see what you
guys got
i would love to answer questions so
let's get the questions
rocking can i explain what blockfi does
so
uh blockfy is a business
that essentially has a number of
products uh we are investors in the
business they advertise on the podcast
um but they basically do exactly what um
kind of your fiat bank or wealth
management services do
so let's start with um the first product
which is you can
take your crypto and if you want us
dollar liquidity but you don't want to
sell the crypto because there's tax
ramifications or whatever
uh you can give them the crypto they'll
take that as collateral and they'll give
you a us dollar loan against it
um it's a pretty compelling product both
from the borrower you don't have to sell
your crypto and you can get a us dollar
loan
uh but also what they'll do is um it's
compelling to them because they have an
over collateralized loan where they have
the collateral
uh and so it really prevents them from
having loss of capital and asset back
lending
the second product um is they've got a
crypto exchange so you just go buy and
sell crypto
and that's pretty self-explanatory uh
and then the third product
is um a product that uh is an interest
bearing account
so uh most of you are basically taking
your fiat currency you're depositing it
in your bank
and they pay you some nominal fee uh in
exchange for that deposit so they may
pay you
you know 0.03 0.05 percent it's got
three to five basis points somewhere in
that range uh
what block fight and what your bank does
is they take those dollars and they go
and they lend them out on the back end
right and sometimes they lend them out
six seven eight ten times
uh through leverage and things like that
block fi essentially does a very similar
thing
um which is uh you deposit cryptos let's
say you deposit bitcoin they take your
bitcoin and they go and they lend it out
they earn interest off those loans and
they pay you a high percentage of
the uh amount that uh they get in that
loan
um and so uh for bitcoin i think they
pay like six percent
uh apy i think on stable coins
uh it's eight point six percent um so
there's pretty high of rates of interest
there
uh in in terms of um block five you know
obviously we're
very big investors uh i have literally
invested
um eight figures in the business um and
kind of believe
that uh people want to use their
cryptocurrency the same way that they
use
cash that includes uh for payments but
it also includes all sorts of wealth
management services and so block files
going out to do that
but that's kind of how it works and and
we're super excited
um you know i i've a user of the product
um
and uh been a very happy user for uh for
quite a while
what's my thoughts on the grayscales
commercial so i just saw the commercial
for those that don't know grayscale is a
big
asset manager they may be the biggest
asset manager in the digital
asset space they're now running a
national commercial
across a whole bunch of different tv
channels
and uh look they basically are
positioning a narrative
where if you want to be part of this new
digital world
you should invest in digital currency so
i already saw a bunch of comments
they don't specifically say the word
bitcoin um they show
all of their investment assets right so
they've got everything from bitcoin to
ether i think they even have like
ethereum classic
a whole bunch of these things um but
what ends up you know
kind of being true at a macro level is i
generally believe
anyone who's doing good work to get the
word out um about this industry about
this space about these assets
um is doing a great job right we need as
much help as we possibly can get to get
more people interested in this and start
paying attention and understanding this
is real um having somebody
uh like grayscale that manages four plus
billion dollars is uh is fantastic
um and yeah i get it people are upset
maybe or some some
portion of people are upset they didn't
name specific assets uh look at the end
of the day
it's one of these things to where i
think michael jordan one time was asked
all right we got jason back now uh but
michael jordan was once asked
why don't you donate any money to
politicians or why don't you ever talk
about politics
and he said republicans and democrats
both buy sneakers
and i think that's what you're seeing
with grayscale which is uh you know at
the end of the day they may have
personal opinions
uh whether you agree with them or not
they definitely do um but what they're
trying to do is try to build a business
and what's the best for business uh for
them specifically my
my assumption or my guess is is to have
people uh
invest in assets regardless of what
their personal belief is in those assets
and so
um it's more of an infrastructure type
uh play where you you just provide
access to a bunch of different digital
uh assets or currencies
uh without actually trying to play you
know kind of king maker or
put your opinion on to others so i see
both sides of the argument but
anytime you've got national commercials
running uh i think it's generally
positive
you good over there man yeah i don't
know what happened was that you or me
nah that was you i thought maybe you
were borrowing peter schiff's dial up
internet for a second
oh yeah that aol i'll
that was legit back in the day i was
gone for a while
right um yeah one other point i want to
make
yeah going back to good money because
this really infuriated me and it's
it sent me on this kind of tour this
mission to write my own book
which i'm working on now
you trade your life working whatever
your profession is whatever it is that
you do
you set out you go and do that you spend
most of your time away from your
family away from your loved ones away
from things that you want to do
in the pursuit of earning enough money
to take care of
life's necessities or make you know
have a little bit more whatever more is
to you
if you're capable of saving something
beyond
what it costs for you to live and have
that little bit more
that should be enough that should be
enough
and the us dollar has proven it's not
enough
like i can guarantee you this and i
can't guarantee you
many things i can guarantee you that
your u.s dollar
is going to be worth less tomorrow than
it is today
agreed i can guarantee you i can also
guarantee you or i can't guarantee
the price of bitcoin in the future but
through all the things that we discussed
today
it appears to me objectively
that bitcoin acts as good money
over time it just it's set up to do that
and i
i can't guarantee that tomorrow
bitcoin's price is going to go up
but it has the framework that if it
works
is far better than the way the us dollar
is set up
yeah i mean look it it is uh
it's understanding the structural
elements and a
very long time horizon right and you
know one of the things i always say
is uh and you're in this category too is
like we have
decades of
life in front of us right or viewpoint
there's a lot of
people um who just don't have that right
so if you're 60 plus years old
like yeah you know look again maybe
you've got
30 years which is awesome right and
hope to god that that's true for
everybody but 30 years versus somebody
like me who's got 60 years ahead of them
if we both die
you know at 90 you know it's just
it's a very very different perspective
um and
i think that one of the key pieces to
investing in general uh that people have
to remember
is uh and and our third partner mark
yusko uh says this all time and i
believe that he's right in it which is
it's all about asset allocation
everyone wants to be like the stock
picker right everyone's like oh this
stock's better than this stock or
whatever
it really just comes down to asset
allocation and so i think that
uh understanding how much do i want
exposed to stocks how much do i want
exposed to
real estate or crypto or dollars or
whatever it is
that decision is going to be much more
important to delivering you returns
than did i pick the right stock inside
of my
stock allocation um and so i think that
people just got to kind of get educated
on that stuff but
ultimately if they can that's where
they'll drive a lot of the returns
yep totally agree right
um all right i'm gonna take two more
questions
uh jason's twitter account is at going
parabolic
uh so is this uh youtube channel so you
go to going parabolic on youtube you'll
find it there
um let's see
let's see here what other questions do
we have
uh what will make you change your mind
on bitcoin that's a great question from
abdi uh i i've been pretty clear about i
think the things that would make me
change my mind
uh number one would be uh that there
is some sort of self-inflicted wound
that is
catastrophic uh to bitcoin meaning that
if all of a sudden there was a software
bug that was introduced to the code
um that you know materially changed it
or made it
susceptible from a security standpoint
or something like that
but that would definitely be one thing
the second thing i think
is if there was uh some
invalidation of supply and demand
economics
sound money those types of things
obviously i don't think that there would
be
but there was definitely a world before
people understood that stuff so maybe
there's some other great thing out there
that we don't understand yet but i don't
think that's coming
um and then ultimately lastly uh i think
that um
what would maybe change my mind about
bitcoin is uh it
being rendered worthless and what i mean
by that
is money is a belief system and it
takes a network effect to make money
valuable uh
if all of a sudden everyone walked away
from bitcoin
it would become worthless right and what
i mean by worthless is like literally it
could go to zero
um and so if that happened i think on
that day everyone who were like the last
defenders of bitcoin
uh would be like well i guess this is
over
right um you know if you kind of go back
and things like e-gold or
uh you know other other uh digital
currencies like eventually they got to
that point
um the way i've thought about it it's
just like i'm willing to go
that far right and uh so
that's why i also am not 100 in bitcoin
um but but i think that uh it's just
understanding kind of your your
limits both in terms of exposure and
then also risk on the downside right
some people say hey i'll put
you know jason may say hey i'll put 15
of my net worth in bitcoin
but if it goes below 5k uh that's a
signal to me of market demand
and also market belief and i'm out right
if it gets to that point
um you know everyone's going to make
their own decision but that's how i kind
of think about changing your mind
you've shown pretty tremendous
conviction though that you're willing to
ride this thing down and buy tremendous
dips i mean i was watching you
on tv in 1718
i think becky quick was asking you while
bitcoin was taking a 75
drawdown are you a buyer a bitcoin and
you you were saying things like
all the way down like i'm i'm bo i'm a
buyer
which i thought was hilarious that was
there right yeah i i mean look it it's
what
jason i always talk about kind of in
private which is um
you either have to have a very long-term
belief in this or not
right and part of what i think is so
interesting is there's been times on
paper in us dollar value uh
we've made a lot of money in bitcoin and
there's been times where we lost a lot
of money in bitcoin
but understanding it's not about like
that that has no inch that literally
could not be
interesting to me it to me is
much more something like watching the
market cap
at what point do we surpass the gold
market cap i don't know when
but the day that happens that'd be much
more interesting to me
than bitcoins individual like an
individual bitcoin hitting a certain
price
right and ultimately it's because it is
finally the market recognizing that it
is a superior store of value it is a
provably
digitally scarce asset so i think that's
the type of stuff that
um you know at least i think about uh
and we'll see what happens right
i've got a question for you which is not
uh
it's along the same lines of what would
kind of shake your
your commitment to bitcoin but it's less
structural
is finding out who satoshi nakamoto is
in any way uh part of your equation that
could shake you from bitcoin
no i'm not i'm not interested at all
uh actually do you think it is a
non-event either way or do you think
that
um finding out who that is
or that group is could be a problem
well it could definitely uh i mean look
that there are
scenarios where it's less than ideal i
don't know if it'd be a problem
but um you know i'm not even going to
spend i'm not going to speculate but
there's definitely let me go to a really
extreme example if it came out that al
qaeda
was the creator of bitcoin right i think
there's a lot of people who would have
you know pretty big issue right be like
oh wait a second hold on
and especially at the government level
right um
no i do not i believe that you know i
don't think osama bin laden created
bitcoin
um uh but with that said um
the reason why i'm not interested is
because i actually think one of the
strongest things for bitcoin is the fact
that nobody knows
right look at the ethereum community
like whenever something goes wrong with
ethereum
i know that's your position that's why i
asked the question so
it appears to me that it would it would
cause you pause if they found out that
craig wright was satoshi nakamoto
there's zero percent chance
in my mind that that is who satoshi is
no i know i'm just throwing out some
i'm throwing out a ridic like in my mind
someone
who may cause you pause
of course there could be right but but i
think that's part of this
is most of the uh people who would be in
the less than ideal bucket
they couldn't keep their mouth shut for
12 years they wouldn't be able to resist
you know whatever it is billions of of
bitcoin that
uh were mined early like it's just
those are the people that um
would be the first to dump the coins you
know when it hit five dollars
right you know or or whatever it is uh
speaking or specula or speculate into
some other investment right because
they're so smart
they would try to leverage it into
that's right
other things right they would you know
go do whatever uh
you know i mean literally the person
that you mentioned who i will not name
uh was like tweeting one time like
billionaire mode or god mode or whatever
the hell he was saying like it's just
like
sure like by the way if that makes you
happy like knock yourself out right like
like if you want to do that stuff in
life like not for me but like knock
yourself out i i make no judgment in
terms of as long as you yourself are
happy
until you then start to try to make
claims that
i think are pretty verifiable or
inaccurate
at least that's my personal opinion um
and so look
we'll we'll see what happens but um you
know
who satoshi is is uh the fact that we
don't know i think is actually a
great great advantage um you know
because
no one's calling up satoshi when bitcoin
dropped from 8 000 to 4
000 in a single day in march of this
year and being like dude what's
happening
right that's fair it has nothing to do
with the creator
it's uh it's interesting though i don't
know all right what what uh before we
wrap up here
jason i gotta go do other things what uh
what what uh
what do you wanna tell the people what
do you got
me yeah you man
uh everyone wants to by the way hold on
before you say anything everyone wants
to know where they can go get that shirt
i can i made it maybe i'll make yeah uh
no i'm opening up a store on going
parabolic i'll sell them there you
should you should definitely sell that
shirt
everyone everyone would buy that shirt
yeah i'm making i'm designing hoodies
right now so
we'll get it all sorted out all right
what else you got for people
nothing man i think uh the end of this
week i'm on um
i'm doing leia halperin's podcast so
it'll be
fun that's her first one um so go check
her out
um i don't know man just trying to buy
some art
we didn't even talk about nfts i'm super
stoked on those
um you know i changed my name to
uh jason sir art pumping williams
uh did you did you see that i was on the
phone with you that night
where i where i pushed that nft's price
by trevor jones to 55 000.
yeah for those that don't for those that
don't know jason was bidding on a piece
of digital art
it ultimately sold for 55 000.
uh and it only sold for fifty five
thousand dollars because he was bidded
all the way up to fifty five thousand
five hundred dollars
and then eventually somebody outbid him
i just fell asleep
i was not i wasn't intending to stop but
it just went on and on
and trevor jones is is real you gotta
check out treasure
trevor jones's art i agree um
all right guys before we let you go
remember to smash the like button that
big thumbs up
hit that so more people will see this on
youtube
uh make sure you subscribe to the
channel go to
going parabolic on youtube that's
jason's channel you can go subscribe
there
uh and then go to pompletter.com and you
can sign up
for the email i send every day that's it
what do they say uh you ain't gotta go
home but you gotta get the hell out of
here
we'll uh we'll see you guys next time
thanks so much guys